succès du film indigènes une semaine
après sa sortie un million de personnes
l'ont déjà vu en france et l'équipe du
film entame une tournée en afrique noire
et en afrique du nord première étape
hier soir le maroc casablanca les
anciens combattants et est aux premières
loges reportage pascal deschamps abd el
ghiwane
certains n'étaient encore jamais allé au
cinéma leur guerre ils la portent à la
boutonnière
mais hier soir mouloud mohammed idris
étaient les héros du film les héros
d'une soirée de gala dans le plus grand
cinéma de casablanca
sincèrement merci d'être venus aussi
nombreux ça veut dire que vous avez été
vous avez été aussi sensibles que nous
vous allez voir c'est pas une comédie
juste très très très heureux de voir que
les salles sont pleines et que les gens
sont aussi sensibles ici que de l'autre
côté et j'ai j'ai le même sentiment j'ai
l'impression que ce film ultime est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est bien de faire
un film sur ce que vous avez vécu à ben
oui mais oui pour montrer beaucoup de
choses madame pour que sur lesquels vous
le montrer le cercle est fils de marc
allard à notre deuxième nationalité
française je n'avais chez la misère kuna
bgc d'information nous a pas payé pour
ce qu'il a fait en écho à ces sentiments
mêlés de fierté d'amertume la presse
marocaine souligne est avec humour les
lenteurs de la politique française parce
qu'il faut ça croit que le président
français regardent un film comme
questions touchant les votations france
maghreb ou france a prises pour que ça
bouge on a atteint notre objectif
après après pourquoi ils n'ont pas été
sensibles à rome pourquoi les choses
n'ont pas été faites
d'une manière plus juste enfin toutes
ces questions les pauses et ne jamais
répondre
après le maroc les cryptes d'indigènes
poursuivra sa tournée en algérie et au
sénégal pour évoquer une histoire
commune sur les lieux mêmes où elle a
commencé